D
THO ULIANI IS GROWG.
A DOCUMENT UEA
TODAY REVEALS PRID LS
E-MAILS FROM FORMER GOIALS.
LET'S GET RIGH KARA SKINNED OF ?
>> WOM AAUHAT PROSECUTEXPANDHID
THE NUMBER OTHEY WARRANTS OD WE
PTAINED A iD
UNE UKRAINIANS.
E MOST I, TH
GI SECUTOREN, SOMEONE THAT
TISEAID TH T
U.ASSADO
REMOVAL OF HE HAD T ON IANI IH H
TTTIE EMAI
MAN
AS THE iBUSINESSMAN ALEXANDER  E
R FRUMAN WERE
ARRESTED AT THE AIRPORT IR
S A BI THE
SEARCH WARRANT F
OFFICE AND HOME AND PARN'
LAING ABILITY TO
R TAIN ANY DOCUMENT TH HIS CLIE
PA> AND PRT TRUMFACING
LEGAL TROUBLE AS WE KNOW
RESPONDED OL THE
JANURO
WHAT'S HIS
WHAT IS HE SAYING?
SPE JANUARY 6tAG HEAD TO
PU T THETIFICATO
HE FOR
JOE BIN S SAYING HE'S
Y HE WASCAUSHIFI SD ALSO BECAUHE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SULE MU LAWSUIT.
OLMUNITY HAS THE CASE THAT
NDAW FORTE SOME TIME ON OTHESUEA
TH PREET
BARRERA.
S ATTORNEY SAYS THTU PTESIDENCA?
>> WELL, YOU TUEG
E BOTH OF H KARA
MENTIONED IN PASSIE IS THAT AS .
THERE ARE LIMITAS HAT
RIGHT TON RR ENGAGE IN SEDITIOUU
DEFENSE ANGITHTU
MAD HE
ERIC SWALWELL'SUSED ALSO FROM W
R WHETHER OROT
MTEAT B WG ACCORDING TO HIS
LAWYERTHHIS
DUTIES AS PRESIDENT, WITHIN
JOB DESCRIPTION AS THE PRESIDENT
AND LEAD O THA
E THINGS HIN AI CAPACITY.
THAT'SEA
TH M GL THE TIME.
EPENDS ON HOYO
ACTIVITY.
IN A VERY DIFFERENT CONTEXT, ICP
HAS S ARGUMENT WITH
EC DEFAMATION CLAIM  EVE.
HE SAID THAT WHAT HE SAIS OPOBGS
S
HOW THE JUDGE VIEWS THE ARGUMEI
T.E HAVE GIULIAN HIS
FORMER PERSOATTORNEY
DEFENDING HIS COMMENTS WHEN HE
THE COMNT WITH TRIAL BY
DOES HE
HAVE?
>> THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
ATTEMPTS AND SPEC LATE
PEHA RUDY GIULIANI ANDDENT
IN SOME  JANUARY 6thS ANMPEACHT
FAILED ULTIMATELY IN THE NN
WE HAVE ANH RESPECT
TO THE CIOUARYSION WHICH M
PARTICIPATIOTHERE'S A TIWHUNY'SL
DOJ IS DOING IT'UNCLEAR.
THE YOOW.NGUAGE CER
GOOD LANGUAGE.
I THIN RUDY GIUL
BECAUSE HE WAS AVA
BETTER
THA
EAND WHO WAS MAKINGPRESIDENT
COMMENTS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
MAHIPI
EAS INTEND WAS IN SOME
WA PY IN DRAMATIC WASEHEN NOT TH
HAVE HIS WORDS ARE NOTPROTECTED
BEEN GOING ON FOO
YEARS.
ARE WE CR TO THE EHAN ING?
YR
>> IT'S HARD TO Y.T THIS QUESTIL
THE TIME WHEN I RA OFFICE,D SOM.
PARTREON
AY ACCORDINGHE REPORI THINK THI
SOURCES, THAT PROSECWANTED
TIS ISES F.
BI BATGENERAL OF THE PRIOR
REQUEST TO EXECUTE THE SEAWAT W.
REPORTING SUGGESTSTHERT WERE
9 CURRENT REPORTING THING ABOUTW
MATERIAL THAT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICN
IT TAKES L
THROUGH, SO  DODGED UR
DICTING, YOU
KN,  TLE
BUT THESIN TTIME.
RUDY INFORMATION.E ISSUE OF
IA THEIR WILL
APPOINTE WILL SIFT THR
WH PRIVILEGED AND
PRIVILEDE
TIME STILL.
>> I'VE COVERED DO ENOUGH
TO KNOW EVEN WHEINK AN
INVESTIGATIOPPIN